hey everyone welcome to my travel day to
CES I'm heading to Vegas for CES I have
to leave my baby boy where's he at
there he is Jenna's on our way over here
to babysit and it's always so sad when I
have to leave him it's tough it's
heartbreaking but he actually doesn't
mind this cage too much you got time to
go in one cage
go ahead Oh bye Maddie I'm gonna miss
you so much my poor sweet boy it's
raining in LA like look at this this is
disgusting we really need it though I'm
meeting Francesca in Vegas and we're
gonna have a really good time so let's
go I just almost killed myself on a TIE
fighter balloon if I was gonna go out
today that's how I'd want to go out
[Music]
we made it my flights an hour delayed I
thought I was gonna miss it
so it's actually works up quite well
because now I'll be on time I'm not
gonna load up on some supplies some
things can be I think
mechanical breakfast sounds fantastic I
[Music]
[Music]
don't know but it just makes you tired
as soon as I get off the plane we're
here for CES and I keep up with
everything that I'm doing at CF retreat
guys are following me on Twitter and on
snapchat and on Instagram and also this
really cool fun app which I know you
guys have heard of its called go 90 apps
and tons of my friends tweeting about it
so they're gonna be doing some cool live
streams you guys can watch all kinds of
hiding stuff interviews product
exclusives so you guys download that
link in the description do they have
live streams from TechCrunch and gadgets
and all kinds are opening so I actually
have my own channel on there too there's
a couple of solution videos I believe
there's one up right now so just go
check it out since you're iJustine
that's my name I can't film now because
we're going into the casino and I always
keep y'all that we are going up to
chancer bar here at all it's called it's
not a lotus flower but some flower he
even then you have a triangle fire it's
not drug verbena and the flower is once
you got to get this you're gonna take
the flower what you do it
guys I just got back to the Francesco's
not feeling well so I have to be very
quiet but I look forward to seeing you
guys at CES and don't forget you I see
me make sure you say hi and now I'm
gonna to this video and post it so it's
up in time for the start of CES good
night I love you
peace out he's so rose
[Music]